[Musique]
revenons aux élections au nouveau
brunswick où on a peu ou pas abordé la
question des arts et de la culture
pendant cette campagne électorale une
industrie qui fait pourtant rayonner la
province bien au-delà de ses frontières
mais les artistes ici pensent qu'il est
encore temps pour eux de se faire
entendre les explications de jimenez
vergara un an après le méga spectacle
hackett dit rock ou francos de montréal
les jeunes artistes se pose de moins en
moins la question s'il peut faire
carrière en acadie sans compromis sans
s'exiler c'est d'ailleurs la thématique
au coeur du documentaire vague des
caddies diffusé cette semaine
le réalisateur phil comeau dresse un
portrait de cette vitalité culturelle
d'aujourd'hui jean besoin de se voir à
l'écran mali vent de l'extérieur on
voudrait nous voir comment on est on est
quand même une une population
francophone qui fait beaucoup de choses
qui influencent souvent des décisions à
travers le pays
que ce soit en musique ou dans toutes
les disciplines artistiques l'industrie
culturelle cherche à se faire entendre
au même titre que les autres industries
dans la province ce message c'est ce que
martèlent les dirigeants de
l'association des artistes
professionnels du nouveau-brunswick
la pole est très sec ou de l'or au
développement d'une société à
l'expliquer tic à allonnes aux jeunes de
meilleurs citoyens fait comme si que on
ne reconnaît pas faire un ministère
dédié uniquement aux arts et à la
culture des investissements substantiels
de 5 millions de dollars
tout passe par la véritable
reconnaissance de la profession de
l'artiste de son statut dans la société
kohona ses 133 millions pib ou noomane
douik presque jamais les emplois et
qu'on fait partie comme des singes
utilisés par tout hollywood rick
meurtrier
en tant que musicien avant gardiste
serge brideau des hôtesses d'hilaire
appuie les revendications du secteur
culturel et un manque de relève dans
l'industrie musicale
selon lui un véritable fonds pour
soutenir la relève dans l'industrie
musicale serait nécessaire les hôtesses
d'hilaire font le pari de rester au
nouveau-brunswick une industrie en santé
permettrait à des artistes comme lui en
musique de se produire ici comme
ailleurs au pays sans avoir à s'exiler
ce que j'aimerais voir et des allemands
en tant que quartier ce qu'on copie le
québec un combat de longue haleine qu'il
compte mener le temps qu'il faudra ici
iman avait des gars d'à à radio-canada
mountain